across the country students are
returning to class to begin a new school
year many classrooms have evolved to
benefit from new technology trading
chalkboards for dry erase boards and
textbooks for iPads but there is one
simple tool that retains a special power
in this morning's reporter's notebook we
examine the use of one of the most basic
writing instruments and all that comes
with it
school is starting again and I'm
sharpening my pencils that's not a
metaphor I'm actually sharpening pencils
I'm not currently enrolled anywhere by
season starts I am reminded of the smell
of the cedar the click of the box lid
and the chime of what rattled inside a
[Music]
survey of friends and colleagues
suggests this is a shared memory we were
all lucky enough to start the year with
fresh new school supplies but this is
not nostalgia to attain that start of
school spark that those boxes of pencils
represent the fresh beginning the idea
of creativity to come and that our lives
can be orderly and sharp give us the
tools and we can finish the job the
humble instrument has also been on my
mind recently because single-use tools
helped us escape from technology there
is no other distracting functionality a
watch tells time a notebook for the
to-do list and a pencil for writing
select the slow food movement but for
work
we know that writing by hand helps us
retain information longer because it
connects us with the process the pages
curl as we press words down on to them
and those words don't go skittering off
somewhere into a computer screen when we
pause to sharpen it is the gentle
interruption that is necessary for
creativity and innovation proof that
pencils help us live deliberately is
that author Henry David Thoreau at one
point created the most popular pencil in
America to escape modernity he moved off
into the woods which is not an option of
to us but to reconnect with those
essential feelings of promise from those
early days at the bus stop we might all
start with a box of pencils